how do you pee in the suit the bottom  half of the suit sort of waist down  they're like a pair of trousers that i  have to slip on i have like a flap  [Laughter]  [Music]  flap that goes from the chest like  underneath my butt crack and it's like  you know i've got this like big hand as  well like these huge fingers and then on  the other side i've got nails that are  glued on so i can't touch anything  without everything falling apart so it's  not very easy and like and shout out  tyler if you're listening because tyler  would have to stand outside the bathroom  door because no one else could come in  because i'm like  hovering over the euro and all that